let's move on to our next topic okay
Jason this one's near and dear to your
heart since you spent the last year
running an accelerator let's talk about
accelerators and incubators so I think
the the question to ask as a founder is
you know is a accelerator or is an
incubator for me is it you know who
exactly is it for yeah I mean that's
it's a great question because they're
certainly not for everybody and it
depends on the stage of your company too
but I think one of the biggest upsides
I've seen is the I mean not oh it's it's
hugely helpful for fundraising for one
but the network you build it's one of my
favorite things of the accelerator from
you know I started when we were in you
know launch incubator - yeah so those
early days of the class going from week
one to week 12 mm-hmm not only are their
pitches better and their confidence in
themselves in the company better but
their best friends you know they have
this they have a cohort now that you
know they're going through something
that everyone else in the room is also
going with going through and it's being
a founder can be very lonely so having
that network is important and then of
course the network outside of that were
the investors and you know everyone else
that's that's part of you know in our
case of the part of the launch network
is is hugely hugely helpful you know
it's the negatives I sort of only see
only see the positives of an accelerator
because I watch that growth yeah but I
think some founders you know the
pushback that we've that we've gotten
from founders is that they don't want to
give up equity in their company right
which is reasonable it's reasonable sure
yeah it's for a second or third time
founder the idea of going to an
accelerator to build your network if
you're Mark Pincus or Evan Williams in
2019 makes no sense but if you were Evan
Williams the founder of twitter and
blogger before that and medium now he
may have very much wanted to go to you
know have blogger be part of an
accelerator if those existed back then
because they do kind of get you to
second or third base which accelerators
or incubators do you think are a
no-brainer to go to Jason I mean
obviously lunch accelerator we like to
believe ours is world-class putting our
sucide when you hear somebody's gone to
X or Y accelerator yeah which ones do
you candidly go that seems like that
would increase the value of the company
and then we won't go ride any other ones
but let's talk a little bit but candidly
about what the downside is to going to
one that maybe isn't in that upper
echelon so who's in the upper echelon
and what's the benefit of that and then
let's go into the next piece so I think
the the you know accelerators incubators
that you know we aspire to you know
continue to work towards and have
inspired us as well YC Y Combinator tech
stars as well I mean both of them have
built phenomenal programs and then of
course we think we've done we think we
think we've built something special here
as well and then you know we do see
founders doing a you know an incubator
or an accelerator hop um
so and this is something that founders
can get can can fall in love with kind
of the process to Ashley's point
building this camaraderie with your
classmates is fun right and you know
having this kind of 12-week sprint or 16
week sprint of working toward something
can can be a lot of fun but it can also
be productive right I mean it could
rally the troops to try to accomplish
something in a short period of time
we've heard that as well and it's true
of Croesus focus in performance true
they can also do the downside it could
also be potentially distracting so if
it's taking you away from building out
your team focusing on sales and kind of
you know quote-unquote doing homework
while you know they may on the
peripherals be helpful to the company it
may not be kind of the core thing that
the founder needs to be spending time
with um and it also is a bit of a sign
if you do have to keep going to multiple
incubators accelerators that you just
keep giving up you know additional
equity you know can you need to graduate
at some point and so at what point you
know what point is too much do you think
be curious to know to you know your
thoughts on that yeah I I have seen
companies have done three or four
accelerators and you start to wonder is
this like the person who has four
graduate degrees and like they're 40
years old and they're going for their
fourth
degree and masters in social work after
doing their you know legal degree and
they just love being an academia and it
it is a phenomenon that there are so
many accelerators out there a lot of
people who maybe aren't successful in
business start an accelerator so I
always like to ask people hey who is
running that accelerator how much time
will you spend with those people and
what's their background take a deep look
and the ones where you know maybe the
person running it hasn't had success or
great success or they haven't had
graduates that are pretty successful
they could actually negative signal so
I'm not going to say specific names of
different accelerators but I do think
some people in the venture community and
we're kind of like we straddle
accelerator and a seed fund and you know
increasingly we're doing series days or
collating them those types of that can
be a negative signal and a negative
signal means people see it and go hmm
three accelerators why weren't you able
to clear market and raise to see around
after that why do you why are you
raising a hundred hundred 50k from three
seed funds instead of doing or three
accelerators instead of moving on what
is the best way to know which program to
go to we typically recommend talking to
the founders so the founder went through
the program email them and find out what
they thought of the program and you need
to take a little with a little bit of
grain of salt of course because there is
some bias and the fact that they've
given up the equity and so they want to
where's that confirmation bias that
would fall into confirmation bias yep
yep so you need to be careful about that
but I think if you ask them two or three
different ways you know oh I like that
really what did you get out of it you
know do you think you would do it again
if you started another company you know
what do your classmates feel the same
way about about the program did anyone
have a negative experience they give you
dig in enough you'll typically typically
find out you know what the how they
truly felt about it
yeah the asking three or four times I
think is really brilliant because with
confirmation bias if somebody's made an
investment in something you own a Tesla
or you bought the Chevy Volt or the
Fisker I remember the
car owners we're like it's better than a
Tesla they would die with this garbage
car being better than a Tesla and it was
obviously not it was a lemon essentially
and you know if you actually ask them
the third time like what did you get out
of it what specific and would you go
back again they say oh I totally and you
say yeah okay
would you really and would it be worth
it at the same terms yeah and sometimes
they will say no hey everybody I want to
take a minute to tell you about eight
sleep they make the pod which is a
really interesting new bed that controls
the temperature both cooling and heating
one on each side so you and your spouse
or significant other can have a
different temperature and it's gonna
make you sleep better this is the
ultimate hack we went to the showroom
and here's the president Sam and our
company going to the showroom and as you
can see the thermo regulation occurs by
that box that's on the floor there and
it makes the bed hot or cold and to
different people as they say can have
different temperatures and it will do
this really interesting thing in order
to wake you up it's gonna do a thermo
alarm which means it's slowly gonna make
the bed a little bit cooler which raises
your heart rate and allows you to wake
up naturally and if you're watching this
video that is a reader and that reader
there tells us the infrared what the
temperature is and you can see on one
side of the bed it's one temperature and
on the other side it's the other and
that will allow you to pick what
temperature you want your spouse or
significant other can pick with the
temperature that they want and you're
gonna sleep much better and sleep is a
critical part of being a great founder
you want to get great sleep and you're
gonna do that with 8 sleep so once you
go to 8 sleep calm sighs twist and
supercharge your health and productivity
try the product risk-free for 100 days
I'm not kidding they will let you try
eight sleep for 100 days risk-free go to
8 sleep calm / twist 8 sleep calm /
twist and check out the pod it is
amazing ok let's get back to this
awesome episode